what do you think about Mark Zuckerberg
on Joe Rogan's podcast saying that the
FBI warned Facebook about potential
foreign interference
uh and then Facebook
inferred from that that they're talking
about Hunter Biden laptop story and
thereby censored it what do you think
about that whole story
again you asked me when I was in the FBI
I wouldn't believed it from being on the
inside I wouldn't believe these things
but there's a certain narrative being
written that is surprising to me that
the FBI is involved in these stories so
but the interesting thing there is
the FBI is saying that they didn't
really make that implication they're
saying that there's interference
activity happening just watch out and
it's a weird relationship between FBI
and Facebook you could see from the best
possible interpretation that the FBI
just wants Facebook to be aware because
it is a powerful platform a platform for
viral spread of misinformation so
in the best possible interpretation of
it it makes sense for FBI to send some
information saying like we we're seeing
some shady activity absolutely but it
seems like all of that somehow escalated
to a political interpretation I mean
yeah it sounded like there was a wink
wink with it
um the the I don't know if Mark
meant for that to be that way you know
like again are we being social
engineered or was that a true uh you
know expression that Mark had and I
wonder if the wink wink is direct or
it's just culture really you know maybe
certain people responsible on the
Facebook side and lean have a certain
political lean and then certain people
on the FBI side have a political lean
when they're interacting together and
it's like literally has nothing to do
with the giant conspiracy theory but
just with a culture that has a
particular uh political lean during a a
particular time in history and so like
uh maybe it could be a hunter buying
laptop one time and then it could be uh
whoever uh Donald Trump Jr's uh laptop
uh another time it's a tough job I mean
if you're the liaison if you're the
FBI's liaison to Facebook uh uh you know
there there's certain people that I'm
sure they were offered a position at
some point it seems we you know there's
FBI agents say goat I know I know a
couple that's gone to Facebook there's a
really good Agent that now leads up
their child exploitation stuff
um
another Squad mate runs their internal
investigations both great investigators
so you know there's good money
especially when you're an FBI agent
that's capped out at a you know a 1310
or whatever whatever pay scale you're
capped out at
um it's it's alluring to to be you know
maybe want to please them and uh and and
be asked to to join them